and we're gonna go ahead and get into
MLB the show 17s create a player and
hunter is going to create Brandon
Crawford's as close as we can get to it
so so far the body looked about right
head shape come on what kind of head
shape would you say Crawford ass I feel
like this one's kind of close shake five
looks pretty good it's one of these two
I think it's this one man you think he'd
be happier you've been putting these all
big cheeks but it's like skinnier than
that so I'm gonna go with this that
looks close we can definitely adjust the
cheeks if if need be - yeah yeah I'm
gonna just head sighs the customization
in this game is absolutely fantastic
all right so then we're gonna have to go
to this shape I don't know no I think
shape five is good be sure to exaggerate
his his finer features I mean who would
you say is the closest in Locker who is
your best your best friend you know I'm
close with a lot of them it's tough to
pick a best friend um you know as far as
like time spent away from the field last
year was Cory Gearrin and Connor
Gillespie we did a lot of playing cards
together so nice but all of them really
man I like I love Parker oh there we go
we got Crawford right there see I'm kind
of close with the place we get the beard
I can nailed it so far I mean I'm trying
to see oh we got so many options here
hair line position we didn't get longer
hair all right so I'm gonna I must skip
all that I think we're all here we go
this is where we need to go
now we're wait where's the long hair I'm
so hit one yeah and then we can check
out some more hairs not him not balding
know how the moment I know it's oh wait
no it's kind of the closest one so far
do you think he'd be happy to hear you
say that
no I mean that could be a to that from
the back looks right yes if we had the
beard this might have to be it long
curly I mean that's kind of what his is
yeah I guess he's the long curly guy
that's it looks good to me that's close
how her he's a little browner than that
there you go white if you want
all right also I just want to mention
you do lot of streaming this is funny I
I do some streaming haven't I gotta get
to setup up but I do like the stream yes
and you stream with your wife
that's called let's get Lexi is the
channel correct actually no I've been
streaming them on just at Hunter Pence
you've been doing your own thing yeah
thank you pitch here uh your wife's
channel yeah let's get Lexi's good too
you can follow that one now pitch his
says how often would you say you you've
been doing some streams in spring
checking I did none before leading up to
spring training I did I would do like
two a week Wow holy cow yeah short ones
we were doing we were playing some magic
the gathering on there was fun I like
doing it I want to get on on there
consistently I just got to get the set
up so once I left Houston I lost like we
had the whole set up in Houston yeah so
I went to spring training and I didn't
have anything to do it there so
hopefully I'll get I'll get a road set
up and I'm super focused I'm not I'm
dialed into getting his uh his beard I
mean that's kind of close there's a
little white stubble so hopefully it'll
be a little more consistent
whenever I get set up here full beard I
guess that's that's the one well while
we're on the subject of look anything
like him or on the subject of beards big
rad asks how do you maintain your sweet
hey you're sweet facial hair hunter how
do I maintain my well last year I've
maintained it by not ever doing anything
to it just gross coming is there any way
to get pulp a picture of last year's
hair I don't know I don't I don't know
if that's possible but that kind of
looks like the color right there I'm
gonna try that on this one
he's the beard lighter than the hair for
him no but I just want to get them kind
of on par it's like it's yeah see now
we're cooking with gas
I mean this principal little darker
minute hey what is this space your
hairstyle you can stack facial hair in
this game which is really cool so you
could have like light stubble with a
nice goatee on top awesome this looks
pretty good now yeah let's prig in
alright now we need a skin colour to be
a little bit more tan let's see maybe
John Chen this is where we can now yeah
he's got like a rounder square face I
think you're doing great
now we gotta get skin might be in body
skin tone
probably the greatest comment ever just
came up on twitch here looks like Merc
DZ said if you google search Hunter
Pence getting his butt kicked
there is no results it just doesn't
happen who said yeah that's Rios zero
results it just doesn't happen
that's super mark DZ great comment great
comment that's pretty funny pretty sure
you can say that about a lot of people
boom dude this is seen six worth or
maybe he's more tan than that though
[Music]
have to get the color just right there's
so many options or no thanks to 20 at
least 225 probably but yeah
let's look swims are way too big oh you
don't give them like real long gone real
short arms
this is they're taking it seriously this
is legit he's got big size calves
yeah dude that's pretty good
look at that wave from right there it's
spot on except for the number 3 5 duh
oh so no Jack it's a jacked version of
crop I'm in nicely done nicely done
alright so there you have it
Brandon Crawford go ahead put it in the
game cancel one they already made we
just made one it's better
[Music]